you are a UFC commentator yes and I
never saw that coming and I listened to
you and you're really good at it
you're a very you're very entertaining
but it's strange because it's one of the
most active intense violent kinetic
sports and you are the most laid-back
guy I've ever met
do you find it does it do I mean how
does that fit how does it work for you I
think that some fights will get me up
beat and get me over the top because
it's based off of the fight that I'm
watching if it's a real entertaining
fight in this action pack then I believe
that my commentary will be action-packed
but for the most part I'm just playing
to the fight and I just love the UFC
because you can't run in that in that
industry it's not like you can hide in
the corner you got to really get out and
that's that's exciting to see and
exciting to commentate do you ever find
yourself let's say you're watching a
game a match at home would you ever find
yourself up and like shadowboxing you
know do you jump around I get I'm very
kinetic so if I'm watching something I
jump up and I get involved do you ever
do that
no not yeah not we're fighting because
fighting is different you know I'm
saying it's like I don't know shadowbox
cuz I'd rather fight somebody for real
and get them really you don't seem like
a guy who would want to fight someone
what is your fighting style you have a
style my fighting style is a big knee
it's ignant big now that means this any
style at any time and it's whatever I
might bite I might check on my pole or
my this is fighting there's no rules
yeah I can relate to that I will do
whatever I have to do in that moment
mostly I flail around but you know you
and I have similar builds we're both
very tall and what I do is I just yes I
like that you and I were fighting it
would just be the two of us
right here like this that's it yeah
sacred it really it looks like a used
car lines you've got blowing
[Applause]
you